PLAIN BRIAN YOU PROBABLY HEARD
CONGRESS PASSING $900 BILLION
RELIEF BILL AFTER NEGOTIATIONS,
FEEBLELY GOT ON TRACK AND THEY
SIGNED SOMETHING.
THEY AGREED TO SOMETHING.
SUPPOSED TO BE TARGETED DIRECT
AID TO RESTAURANTS SUPPOSED TO
BE IN THE DEAL.
IT’S NOT IN THE DEAL 110,000
RESTAURANTS CLOSED PERMANENTLY
SINCE MASH WHILE 2.1 MILLION
RESTAURANT WORKERS LOST THEIR
JOBS.
OUR NEXT GUEST OWNS SIX
RESTAURANTS, TWO BARS BEFORE
THIS PANDEMIC AND HAVE SINCE HAD
TO CLOSE TWO OF HIS RESTAURANTS
AND ONE OF HIS BARS.
HE IS HERE NOW IS RESTAURATEUR
HIMSELF ROBERT ST. JOHN.
ROBERT, WHAT WERE YOU HOPING WAS
IN THE $900 BILLION DEAL AND
WHAT IS IN IT THAT WILL HELP
YOU?
>> WELL, I’M TALKING TO YOU FROM
HATTIESBURG, MISSISSIPPI AND OUR
SENATOR, SENATOR ROGER WICKER
TOOK THE LEAD ON THIS THING BACK
IN MAY AND INTRODUCED THE
RESTAURANTS ACT CONGRESSMAN
BLIEWRM HOUR IN THE HOUSE
INTRODUCED THE HOUSE VERSION, IT
PASSED.
THE SENATE VERSION HAD 53 PEOPLE
ON ON BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE.
WHEN YOU GOT CHUCK SCHUMER ON
ONE SIDE AND LINDSEY GRAHAM ON
THE OTHER SIDE.
DICK DURBIN, JOHN POORMAN, 53
SENATORS SIGNED ON BUT WE DIDN’T
GET IT IN THIS NEW LEGISLATION.
HOLDING OUT LITTLE HOPE THAT
WHEN CONGRESS COMES BACK THIS
NEXT CONGRESS IN JANUARY THE
RESTAURANTS ACT WILL BE A PART
OF THAT.
BECAUSE WHAT PEOPLE DON’T
UNDERSTAND 500,000 INDEPENDENT
RESTAURANTS IN THE AMERICA.
NUMBER TWO INDUSTRY RIGHT BEHIND
HEALTHCARE.
YOU HAVE GOT IS 1 MILLION PEOPLE
WHO WORK IN INDEPENDENT
RESTAURANTS.
ALSO 5 MILLION PEOPLE IN
ANCILLARY BUSINESSES LIKE
FARMERS, FISHERMEN, PEOPLE LIKE
THAT THAT ARE JUST, YOU KNOW,
DESPERATE RIGHT NOW.
IT’S ROUGH OUT HERE.
BRIAN: AND I AGREE WITH YOU
100 PERCENT.
ROBERT, SO THIS THING HAPPENS.
IT HITS IN THE WINTER.
THEY TELL TO YOU SUCK IT THROUGH
THE SPRING.
WHAT DID YOU DO IN ORDER TO
REOPEN?
GIVE US AN IDEA OF THE
INVESTMENT YOU PUT IN TO BE
RESPONSIBLE BAR/RESTAURANT OWNER
MY FIRST RESTAURANT WAS IN 1987
FLAGSHIP RESTAURANT.
IN MARCH SERVED LAST MEAL BEFORE
THE SHUT DOWN NOT KNOWING IT
WOULD BE THE LAST MEAL WE EVER
SERVED OF THE BUSINESS MODEL
THERE WASN’T GOING TO WORK GOING
FORWARD AS YOU SAID SIX
RESTAURANT AND ARE BARS.
SITTING -- EVERYBODY IS IN DIFFE
STATES.
I’M TALKING TO YOU FROM OUR KIND
OF BREAKFAST COMMUNITY CAFE.
AND, YOU KNOW, IT CLOSED FOUR
MONTH.
AND OTHER RESTAURANTS WERE SHUT
DOWN FOR A FEW WEEKS.
I HAVE FRIENDS IN COLORADO WHO
DID GREAT WHEN YOU HAD OUTDOOR
DINING, RIGHT NOW IT’S SNOWING
THERE.
IT’S DIFFERENT ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY.
I THINK RESTAURATEURS WE AREN’T
REALLY USED TO ASKING FOR HELP
AND WE ARE A LITTLE ILL EQUIPPED
TO DO IT.
WE ARE IN A BRUTAL BUSINESS.
WE HAVE LOW MARGINS.
YOU KNOW, WE DEAL WITH A LOT OF
CONTROVERSY ALREADY.
BUT WE AREN’T USED TO ASKING FOR
HELP.
AND 2008 CAME AND WENT AND THE
FINANCIAL CRISIS YOU DIDN’T HEAR
A WORD FROM US.
I LIVED ABOUT AN HOUR NORTH OF
THE GULF OF MEXICO.
THERE WERE SIX HURRICANES THAT
CAME THROUGH THE AREA.
THIS YEAR WHEN THAT HAPPENED WE
OUR BRITCHES AND GET BACK TO
WORK.
THIS IS.
BRIAN: THIS IS UNBELIEVABLE.
ROBERT, THE NUMBERS DO NOT SAY
THAT YOU GUYS ARE A SUPER
SPREADER.
IN THEIR HOME.
WHAT IS YOUR MESSAGE TO
LAWMAKERS KEEP SHUTTING YOU DOWN
AND LIMITING YOUR CAPACITY?
>> WELL, MY MESSAGE WOULD BE
SIGN THE RESTAURANTS ACT SIGN
THE INDEPENDENT RESTAURANT GROUP
I’M A PART OF IN MARCH TOOK THE
LEAD AND WORKED WITH SENATOR
WICKER IN THE SENATE.
I SAW THE STUDY YOU ARE TALKING
ABOUT IN NEW YORK FROM SEPTEMBER
TO NOVEMBER.
AND LIKE 74% OF THE SPREAD CAME
FROM HOUSEHOLDS AND GATHERING
EVENT AND 1.4% CAME FROM
RESTAURANTS AND BARS.
AND SO, YOU KNOW, WE’RE USED TO
DEALING WITH THE HEALTH
DEPARTMENT.
WE’RE USED TO HEALTH ISSUES WHEN
IT CAME TIME TO PUT ON MASKS AND
PUT ON GLOVES AND HAVE
SANITIZER, WE DEAL WITH THAT
KIND OF THING ALL THE TIME.
BRIAN: IT’S UNBELIEVABLE.
I JUST THINK THAT IF SOME OF
THESE POLITICIANS WORKED IN THE
RESTAURANT BUSINESS, THEY
UNDERSTAND WHAT YOU GUYS DO ON A
REGULAR BASIS.
BECAUSE YOU HAVE THE FREE
MARKET.
IF YOU’RE NOT SAFE, IF IT IS NOT
CLEAN, IF IT IS NOT A PLACE, YOU
WILL GO OUT OF BUSINESS.
ALL YOU WANT IS THE OPPORTUNITY
TO BE SUCCESSFUL AND THESE
POLITICIANS HAVE ROBBED YOU OF
THAT.
BECAUSE THEY SAY THEY WANT TO
LOOK OUT FOR YOU.
AND TO ME THAT IS SO INSULTING.
>> YEAH, BRIAN, 20% OF THE JOBS
ALREADY LOST IN THIS PANDEMIC OF
ALL JOBS CAME STRAIGHT OUT OF
THE FOOD AND BEVERAGE BUSINESS.
AND IT’S ESTIMATED THAT 85% MAY
CLOSE PERMANENTLY.
AND WE ARE TALKING ABOUT -- I’M
NOT TALKING ABOUT FRANCHISE
RESTAURANTS OR BIG CHAINS OR
ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
I’M TALKING ABOUT MOM AND POP
RESTAURANTS, INDEPENDENT
BUSINESSES, LIKE THE ONE -- I
WAS 26 YEARS OLD WHEN I STARTED
THIS THING AND WORKED 90 HOURS A
WEEK FOR THE FIRST FOUR YEARS IN
A HOT KITCHEN AND LOVED IT.
AND I LOVE THIS BUSINESS.
AND I’M GOING TO STAY IN THIS
BUSINESS.
YOU HAVE GOT PEOPLE ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY JUST LIKE THIS THAT ARE
JUST FIGHTING TO SURVIVE RIGHT
NOW.
BRIAN: EVEN IF YOU ARE GREAT AT
IT IS SO INTENSE IT BRINGS THAT
FAMILY ATMOSPHERE BECAUSE HAVE
YOU GOT TO TURN THE TABLES OVER,
SEAT THE PEOPLE AND CLEAN UP AND
AT THE END OF THE NIGHT
EXHAUSTED AND GO OUT AND GET A
DRINK TOGETHER AFTER.
THAT’S WHY IT’S HARD FOR AN
OWNER LIKE YOU TO TELEWORKERS I
CAN’T PAY YOU ANYMORE, THEY
CLOSED ME UP.
IT’S LIKE FAMILY.
MORE THAN ALMOST ANY OTHER
BUSINESS THAT I WAS ABLE TO
WORK..
IN ROBERT ST. JOHN, I CAN’T
THANK YOU ENOUGH FOR JOINING US.
AND HOPEFULLY THIS RESTAURANT
ACT WE WILL KEEP TALKING ABOUT